manipulations génétiques suite nous
avons évoqué hier soir la première
mondiale réalisée par des scientifiques
écossais qui ont réussi à créer un clone
d'animal à adultes à savoir une brebis
de sept mois à cela à partir d'une seule
cellule une cellule unique prélevés sur
le pic d'une autre brebis et donc sans
spermatozoïdes
ces manipulations suscite de vraies
espoir pour les chercheurs mais aussi de
véritables interrogations morales évoqué
par ce reportage de jean dell fait
acquis et bernard ronfler pourra-t-on
demain chez l'homme créé à partir d'une
seule cellule un second exemplaire en
tout point identique avril que certaines
fois ça serait un véritable cauchemar
au salon de l'agriculture les moutons de
race de recettes en est encore bouche
bée et penser à dolly laniel dont tout
le monde parle aujourd'hui dolly n'est
pas un mouton banal c'est un clown la
copie conforme de sa mère elles se
ressemblent trait pour trait de lits a
été en effet conçu sans le moindre petit
spermatozoïdes pas de papa bélier
entièrement fait à partir de cellules
femelles 1 au motif de sa mère dont on a
angers loyaux à la passe de ce noyau en
ami solide une cellule de la glande
mammaire de la brebis équipé de tous les
gènes nécessaires l'ovocyte ayant son
compte de gênes a cru avoir été fécondés
et l'embryon s'est développée 150 jours
plus tard on pouvait dire hello dolly
cette technique si elle fonctionne
pourra permettre de fabriquer en grande
quantité des animaux transgéniques
ces animaux tellement utile pour étudier
certaines maladies humaines
mais le risque c'est le passage à l'être
humain
il y a des milliers de vos sites
congelés et peut être quelques pages un
savant vous est ce que nous clonés est
ce que faire exactement notre doublant
tous faire quelque chose pas pour une
personne mais simplement comme un objet
est ce que c'est digne d'une personne
humaine
alors je crois que c'est la question
qu'il faut se poser est la variation pas
technique
techniquement probablement on va
résoudre petit à petit toutes les
difficultés
la barrière six barrières il ya et
j'espère qu'il y aura sereine barrières
morales et c'est vrai qu'il ya deux
méthodes plus naturelles
et même plus agréable dit certains
connaisseurs pour faire des petits
clowns